Have you all heard the Tamtam song? The same
Tamil one, do you guys understand its lyrics? I
don't know it at all, but I like the
song so much, I don't know
why. Right, similar in our life when we are
studying.  So it is possible that
we may not like any topic of Maths or we may not like
any topic of it, we may
not like any topic of Chemistry,
it does not mean that that NTR
subject is useless and I finish is useless,
tire chemistry is useless, no.
Not at all, especially children make mistakes when
they have to do a subject, so do
not judge any subject on the basis of just one topic. If you don't think,
I didn't understand maths at all,
you think I don't know it.  If you find it then
I have to drop you otherwise do
not change any subject for one topic
because this is the question of your career Question
[Music]